the meeting
I'd brilliant thank you in any way I've
been broadcasting council's YouTube
channel uh continuing on to my media
rights councilor Lawrence wall she was a
vice chair of this committee
so I left and right to council officers
from planning
and highways
to the gender prior to one attendances
to local attendance you can just have
and any apologies we have apology to see
anything else accordingly and councilor
have grown
councilors
192 decorations of Interest members to
give notice of any personal or Prejudice
for interaction related that interaction
on the agenda in accordance with the
adoptive care of conductors declare an
interest
because so I I do for hellbounds
obligation which is one one two one
seven
you go to accuse yourself yes okay
Supply
Council bacon
being defensive
foreign
can you hear me now I hear you now I
haven't heard that yet
it's just the sake of the audience uh
yeah okay uh excuse myself for one one
two one seven which is application thank
you councilor Council speaking
I'll be recusing myself from the event
City application
did you hear that
that's the audience yes
fantastic thank you
item three minutes
you should received in so many terms of
approved correct record the minister the
meeting held on 10th of August 2023 head
up closer
every chance in a second cancel that
there's minutes are so approved as
report questions for members of the
public we have no questions
this evening item five additional
information report to considered a
report if they had a planning and
development super tabled after meeting
this report has been so terrible
item six applications for permission to
development to consider the attached
reports from the head of planetary
development for the following
applications we have seven tenants to
process is the same in each case the
items introduced by a member of the
planet C
if you have speakers on the item and
then speak next and we'll probably get
three minutes
towards members just five minutes I'll
then open the item of the debates and
then the committee early another
decision vote the first item on the
agenda tonight is 111318.
[Music]
this person
thank you chairman
this application relates to the former
events City site close to Trafford
Center you can see it on the Cyber
um
planning permission was granted but it's
now expired for a single well-being
Resort on this site in March 2020.
the revised proposals include a striking
largely glazed main building which will
accommodate variety of health and
wellbeing facilities including swimming
pools other builders Saunders treatment
Marines and water sites
and certainly the site includes
Landscapes areas Gardens swimming pools
Natural Pools whilst to the rear of the
site is to be opened up to the
Bridgewater canal
the site includes Logistics Hub on the
Mercury way parts of the site which is
uh over here
um
let's move to the next slide
you can see sorry bear with me
which out here the main car parts
um one is here to the rear of the site
and there is another one over here off
of mercury way
um
in terms of arrival there are three main
pedestrian
entrances into into the site there's one
to the South here which is probably most
convenient for those using Metrolink
um one two the East which would be most
convenient for those people using the
Mercury way car park and then once the
north for people perhaps using the main
cardboard coming in from Bridgewater
canal
in terms of vehicular access and parking
um this side here the visual at the top
of the screen illustrates the the main
vehicular route into the site you can
see the Bridgewater Canal down here on
the left comes in down Phoenix way a man
is a Subterranean route going underneath
the plaza here and actually the main car
parking area which is which is here
three levels of car parking
three levels of car parking which you
can see at the bottom of the slide
there's one level there
um that's the lowest level and then
there are two further levels to the left
or to the right you get that of the the
main plaza
and that side illustrates the the
Mercury Wayne car park here that can be
accessed directly from Mercury Wayne
um or from service road which runs from
the main car park through the site into
here
um the thinking is that when the
facilities quiet people use the main car
park but when it was busy and that was
full uh people would then
to be able to use the Mercury weight car
park and the likelihood is that it will
be signage to direct people to that
directly when uh the main car park is
hooked
these next two slides show you the
elevations of the buildings
um and really not that easy to see on
there but you can see that they can
result in the form of various glazed
structures
um these are actually easy to see on the
um illustrations that have been
submitted by the applicant was one good
for you there that's taken from the
aerial shop that's taken for just
outside button Square as you can see
we've got the square here feel its way
down there this is bottom right here
and then the second one here with the
Bridgewater Canal down in the bottom
left corner
um looking Garden the rest of the site
this is the car part two it's about the
square
and that's a view of what the the
facility might simply look like from the
landscape Gardens within the site
and there's a shot from uh from one of
the buildings which illustrates how it
might look if you visited the facility
objections have been submitted in
relation to the scene and are covered in
the main report and the additional
information report
the main issue being that's a potential
impact on the operation of the highway
additional traffic counts have been
undertaken by the applicant but work is
still required to a plate traffic
modeling impacts following comments from
cfgm and local Highway Authority
that said cfgn and the local home with
Railway Authority have no objection to
the scheme of principle but a condition
is recommended in the additional
information report requiring further
modeling work to be undertaken this may
ultimately require the applicant to
implement traffic mitigation measures
prior to the facility opening
The Proposal is considered to be in
accordance with the development plan for
the national planning policy framework
and rather than local and National
planning guidance and being acceptable
with regards to matters of design
amenity parking on all local material
planning considerations
the applications considered to compliant
with the development plan and is
therefore recommended for approval thank
you
thank you Mr Pearson do we have Mr
Edwards in the public area
hello thank you Mr Edwards if you press
the microphone and I've got three
minutes to speak in one year
overall my life is just very politely to
uh it's a screenshot okay thank you so
if everyone hear me okay
great good evening thank you for any of
the opportunity to speak to the
committee on behalf of regard this
evening uh my name is Mark Edwards I'm a
direct from low transport planning we're
a specialist development Highway
consultancy we've been commissioned by
regarded to review the access strategy
in highways implications of the proposed
burnt spa resort of the operational Fair
UK HQ facility as I'm sure members will
be aware regardless of the global
business and a major employer on
Trafford park with around 400 staff
based in their HQ we've got to have have
significant concerns with proposed
development of juice post connections
over Mercury way to the coach drop-off
pickup facility the multi-story car park
and Logistics are all of which will have
a detrimental impact on magenta's access
and operations there are also concerns
about transparency in the planning
process and the accessibility of
documents will be available for public
school today principally with a number
of documents not being available in the
public domain which relates to transport
planning and highways matters it is
foreign
information has been proposed to be
submitted by the applicant after the
committee report was prepared which
leads insufficient time for interested
parties such as regarded to review and
also for the local health authority to
provide an accurate memory patience this
time in community we got to wish to
objective application on the basis of
two key access to highways related
patterns number one the robustness of
the traffic impact assessment work
submitted by the applicant to consider
the impacts of the proposed development
of Highway Safety and the severe impact
on the road Network more specifically
the operation for gutters UK HQ and its
400 employees number two the inability
that follows development to be able to
deliver key element to the access
strategy without Landing the ownership
of regatta most notably The Pedestrian
emergency link over the data land for
which no rights of access are in place
nor will be granted our objection letter
says how the detailed reasons for these
objections are in summary it confirms
that there are fundamental issues with
the typical highways analysis and it is
by the application which does not
adequately demonstrate that
post-development will not have adverse
impacts on highway safety uh or generate
a severe impact on the operation of the
high rate Network post development is
therefore it failed so for president
therefore parents comply the National
Party policy code work that promotes
development cannot be delivered without
the use of a land owned by Regatta the
data has no intention of providing
access over their lands you have any
rights that exist currently now or in
the future meaning that if the planning
permission is granted the scheme has
proposed is undeliverable a matter which
is still not been addressed since 2020
when the previous commission was granted
is therefore respectfully requested that
the application has presented be refused
by the committee this evening or is the
minimum deferred in order for a robust
traffic impact assessment can be
presented which adequately considers all
high-risk matters and the rights of
access issues can be addressed by the
applicant thank you very much
thank you
thank you Mr Edwards
is Mr Russell
[Music]
thank you Mr submission
you'll get three minutes once you press
the button if you have a role of the
blood out thank you
thank you
thank you good evening Mr Edwards thank
you for your comments
since our first planning application was
approved in March 2020 we were invested
our time and our money in community
engagement
and design refinement leading the to
this very very much improved scheme
I don't intend in any way to respond to
the objection I think they've been
formally responded to very correctly in
the previous correspondence we have all
had together up to this point including
the traffic surveys and the issues
related to access I would like to spend
some time talking about three areas
which we focused on over the last months
in terms of creating this planning
application to you they revolve around
sustainability the surrounding
environment and accessibility three very
very important issues to the chaplain
community so in terms of sustainability
we have doubled the Quantum of Green
Space utilized on the scheme we're built
on the concept of our relevant Farms
it's the production of our own food and
the utilization of the canal as our
source of transportation of that food
uh we have driven our iodine diverse net
gained to 155
um and many of you will know that when
the scheme is mandatory in November of
this year uh that represents uh 145
growth because the scheme will be 10 so
we're at 155 higher diversity net debt
we've also you've driven use of um 3D
printing with the use of polymathic acid
to go for the privately gradable product
in terms of surroundings with the Vault
they're designed from one structure as
you may have seen in the third previous
application to a collection of
structures within the landscape the
uteruses are connected to the canal The
Greening of Phoenix way to stay in place
and we've increased I've called the
ground emphasis
to close the last one is accessibility
where we've introduced assets three
entrances not one that is all about
ensuring that we maximize the public
access to this through the Metro Link
which is the dean developed and utilized
since our first application reducing
traffic in this area
the same contributes over 4.5 billion to
the UK instead of the UK based on the UK
study done by PWC
at our consultations in June uh
following these three areas we had 91 of
people seriously 21 people supporting
the view that scheme design was much
improved I thank you very much for
listening
uh thank you Mr Russian but before I
just throw it open to debug Mr Pearson
could you suggest a term points made by
uh Mr Edwards one around my location
process
I mean the submission documents have
been available on the website since the
application is submitted
um we were however late reporting the
highway property the initial Highway
property comments on the website and
those from tfqm that's supervised
comments from both cfgm and the highway
privacy have been submitted a very late
devices today in fact but they are also
now on the website but they obviously
relate to the highway authorities
assessment of the sleep over ski was
there for Regatta to look at in anything
so certainly that one in terms of the
landownership issue I mean this is not a
plan in consideration but we are assured
by we get uh sorry by further contrary
to what the gases have said that they
have full access rights Across The
Landing question so that people will be
able to move freely from from the
Mercury website across the guests land
onto the main site
thank you generation
satisfied that
um
the tricks isn't the right and reference
points given the units of the site and
we've used those principles and based on
this per class which is a maximums so
they're very comfortable that we've got
something which represents what the what
they're likely it is in terms of shared
trips which is mentioned regarding um
trips and that basically what that is is
where some where someone visits a
location or if your shopping center or a
lack it out here where you've got all
the uses locally then we don't count
that as in brand new trips what we see
that people will visit several of those
locations so for instance
[Music]
some of those would already go into it
another shop within the Trap Center
likewise
facilities there are a lot of things
around it so the attitude
I think so what they've used as a 50
percent
a rationale of
during the trips if you like we feel
that's reasonable that you can't it goes
greater than that
50 sometimes so we think that's probably
under eight but we're going to let it
it's over prescribed the only the
unemployment we have
um which has been conditioned
um in allergy subjects is around the
deduction but without any extension
discussion
impact
on the network
and there are authentication schemes you
can't put in mostly likely to be not new
Junctions or anything like that but most
likely to be and intelligence around the
area and putting like the MS signing to
direct people away from my identity
there is up so they didn't reboot around
the network so we manage the network
to speak
you know putting all the efforts and
preparing this fantastic report I think
it holds all the points I have to
understand
um
but I think it's a fantastic you know
plan and it reminds me of you know
similar
result in Oslo which I visited and you
know I was hoping that you know one day
we'll have you know similar thing for I
think I see that happening around quite
excited about it
um the report which is prepared it
covers all the points and all the points
made around you know the traffic issues
or the number of people it's just
fantastic you know I'll be proposing to
you that we approve it thank you
thank you
thank you councilman
yeah the risk of sounds like a culture I
have got some concerns about this
application
at a time when more and more of our
planetary boundaries are being crossed
which threatens our very survival I find
it curious that we're being asked to
agree to this development which although
it has the commendable goal of
well-being for an office some
sustainability and biodiversity is in
fact raising artificial environment than
Urban Beach and using up a lot of
resources to do so I don't personally
think we can use the argument that
visiting the facility would be less
carbon intensive than flying abroad I
realize that according to the current
planning regulations there are no real
grounds to a positive development but I
would hope that the conditions placed on
the developers a view of issues such as
sustainability resilience and carbon
impact are extremely demanding in light
of the climate crisis
I also hope that the developers exceed
these conditions that I've been had some
insurance today and really take this
opportunity to use the privilege they
have in developing this site to Showcase
an expert model of how fast active
elements can go in terms of addressing
the climate crisis and messaging
positively how they are doing this and
being a real excellent
I'm concerned about the amount of
parking two multi-story car parts when
there is a medical link there and I hope
there will be incentives for visitors
and employees to use public transport
I'm also concerned about the amount of
water that may be required when extreme
weather conditions may affect our water
resources
in addition I feel that this development
exemplifies some inequalities in our
society and the entry will only be
affordable some not all particularly in
relation to those who would really
benefit from thermal baths for example
who may well be on a low income and not
able to access the facility due to
distance or disability I hope that
offers such as social prescribing and
concessions can fully address these
concerns I also hope that some of the
garden's green areas will be freely
accessible
I'm also concerned about the impact of
yet another development to Trafford
Center on the local residents who are
already suffering from poor air quality
traffic congestion litter and noise it's
estimated that there will be 1.5 million
visitors a year
so although there appears to be now
legitimate ground supposedly application
would like to be reassured that all
conditions are fully met and exceeded
thank you
thanks Jeff
um I'd also um Echo counselor adequate
concerns and one of my biggest concerns
um
probably one of the reasons I thought
the objective is planning application is
the Bridgewater Canal is one of one of
the most special sites I think we've
been transfer and I think it's it as it
says in the report it is a site of
biological importance I walk and cycle
up a Bridgewater Canal
um probably most weeks of the year and I
do it in the daytime I know in the
evenings in the evening one of this
one of its special things is it's pretty
much kept dark all along the way of the
Bridgewater canal and because of that
you you can cycle along it and that will
be cycling along with you it's
incredible and I think we're making a
big mistake in it allowing them to build
Landscaping right up to the creek water
canal it will break that
um that kind of vegetation to go prolong
it that keeps the ecology the way it is
and opening up in the way that they are
I know that it's Landscaping
in a good way but I think in opening up
in the way that they are they what our
liking
that and this now will be nearby to the
car parks and I think it's a break in in
the canal that that will hurt that kind
of biological importance and I don't
think the mitigation of the gmeu
suggested the mitigation enough
um you can put up that Boxes Etc but if
you are breaking that vegetation you are
disturbing a place where bats and other
Wildlife live and you know that
nighttime importance is
special so that's one reason why I won't
be supporting
um
the
um another one is the parking which
councilor I haven't just mentioned the
Trafford Center already has 18 car parks
that host 11 500 car parking spaces but
yet this application is proposing to add
another 1 600 places that traffic center
area putting it up to around kind of
Thirteen thousand points and I just
don't think that's needed as we're told
by
um of traffic officer people will be
already traveling to the traffic center
for other reasons and using these other
car Parks but we're creating even more
car parking spaces again we're inviting
more cars to visit with more highways
impact and you know I've got great
concerns about the level of Health
parking here and I think if you look at
the travel plan it doesn't go even far
enough to encourage people to cycle
more and take public transport it does
indicate that there is a sustainable
most of the transport in the travel plan
but I don't think they're really doing
enough to move people away from a car
predicated
um Leisure attraction so I've got really
great concerns about that too like
Council Oxford and
the energy strategy which I I think is
key because we do want to see those
carbon reductions and we are told in the
report of paragraph 105 that the energy
strategy isn't yet developed and I think
we should be able to see that before
um
check this application we want to see
you know that these the carbon is being
decreased in the way that we want to end
as Africans are access at a heavy empty
Leisure attraction so for me I just
can't support this application and I put
those that we project it
uh thank you Council to welcome to uh
councilman Hassan
um I'm on the loving hard on this and I
know there are solutions
I understand issues around
concerns around energy use and the
environment but the repetition as part
of the uh if we do a previous degree
conditions past the as possible approval
I don't accept that we're at the
Landscaping it down to the Bridgewater
Canal I also cycle up and down I do
um I don't think this will be any
detriment to do
that's the overall view near Brookfield
has to be different certainly even I've
definitely going to feel as you start
drop it down
sorry calculator
thank you okay
I'm disagree with my two previous
speakers and of course fully agree with
my colleague Robert and the applicant
has I think he has very precisely and
comprehensively co-workable applicants
sustainability accessibility there are
three employers walking entrance and
there is a productivity of the charms as
well
Center is fundamentally is it is a
shopping center
I mean it is not a residential area
because
already there are thousands of calls
coming every day and going people are
coming from across the country
and and that weekend
as people have sex so 91 people on the
uncertain they said yes it is a good
move when it is it is one of the
stunning addition uh in the travel
center and I will fully support the
application and I appreciate the hard
work official has done in this situation
thank you accounts for your second in
Council of the bars yes
thank you
um
I'll start off from an apology because
I'll forget to do it
um
Mr Walters Mr Richard waltzer sent us an
email this week
around Regatta around the concerns they
have that that's the big issue for me
but I didn't reply to that but I did
read the contents of that email
I've been listening to the comments of
the speaker earlier and uh I generally
think the highways issues have been
dealt with
um this Council does not want to
jeopardize the future of regatta that's
a big important
and it's important to explore it's been
a traffic park for as long as I can
remember
we wanted to stay there but but I don't
say that this development is going to
affect that business that that I have to
say is my biggest issue concerned about
the application
um
or the members of Bravo
can I say green issues and I don't
pretend to be an expert
but I think the benefits of this scheme
far outweight those issues to the
residue and then yeah
my understanding is this development
will apply 600 people that is a lot of
jobs
that'll bring prosperity to those people
who need those jobs it's quite as simple
as that if you like in the same way as
as we get to do and when I'm going to
look through the details and and before
and close things I inquired about almost
the community benefits what are the
community benefits and perhaps I should
get Clarin into this because I live just
across the world and you always close by
the development hereby should not be
this is one of the um one of the the the
duties of the applicant has to apply the
development here by approach interviews
unless until a community strategy has
been submitted and approved in writing
by the local planning Authority
the community youth strategy shall
include measures to encourage the use of
the development of our skills Community
organizations the NHS and disadvantaged
persons and shall be implemented at all
science following development being
first brought into use now that gives me
a lot of confidence and it tells me this
developer
this applicant is interested in the
community and that's what we're
interested in we're interested in the
gutter because they're providing jobs
they're interesting so this development
it will attract people and there will be
traffic or people will gain a lot of
pleasure from this application
the job effect that you get excited
about it I hear what those things far
out with those benefits and I'll be if
it's not been safe in the chair husband
said if I've been fed this application
thank you very much
okay thank you councilor councilman
thank you chair I'm confused and we
really appreciate
um another person explaining to me if
what I've read in um
the letters from Regatta if it's their
own it belongs to them how can firm then
use that road I don't understand that
thanks
yeah I'm just trying to floor it to
Australia to try and go straight
off the screen before I've had a chance
um obviously understand that the
contention relates to this strip of
green land here
and if you can see my curse on the
screen
um and it's the right of access across
across that strip of land there to
enable people parking in uh the Mercury
wake up up or using the um you know the
logistics Hub here to get into the main
facility and on the back of your work
course
um you know Regatta say that um vote
don't have a right of access across
there firm as as we're calling by firm
that they have undertaken it on the same
extensive legal checks and they are
confident that they have that right now
even if like what I mean what it's not a
plan in consideration
um you know it's between the two parties
but even if that was to be the case
Thermo could still implement this
facility it's just that they would lead
to anybody parking over here
would need to use one of the other
facilities so you know people could walk
the phone could lay out many bus service
or something like that to take people to
to the main facility so I think there
are ways around that even if firm is
assumption that they do have a legal
rights of access across that road isn't
great
um I don't understand why Regatta is
wishing this to be refused because if
anything it's going to improve the
aspect of their headquarters and and the
quality of life for their employees it
looks fantastic this is a kind of
Brokenhearted aspirational
personal budgets could use them to go to
this kind of place and receive Mass
Effect
it doesn't need to be a rich job in
place at all
um there are green comments about the
increase in the car Parks they just
don't buy that the existing site is just
part of concrete and metal boxes so I do
not understand that argument at all
because this will actually increase
screen spaces and Beauty at the place
and thus providing reduced risk of
filling
home the offices conditions are
extensive and thorough and reasonable
which for me provides all the assurances
that I need this will be around for the
project
um so just to find find and make the
final one this regards his threats in
the letter to resolve that they will not
provide access to their name and if this
is granted I think is is platform and
completely lost me to be honest uh maybe
something's very mindful for future
um lessens the planning committee so our
proposing a favor with this thank you
thank you counselor so Google section
that we accept this all those in favor
of acceptance
very nice
okay that should be the plastic
recommendation questions
on the agenda is
um
[Music]
that's the service for a couple of
minutes
[Music]
oh
okay
yeah
thank you
[Music]
so the next application for members will
let you and
I've
trees
the process to subdivide font and direct
a new two-story drawing
the application is reported to finally
committee following the seats of six
objections from local residents the
objections relate to design scale and
dominance and science
impact on amenities Australian residents
and the crews have been overbearing and
of course of overlooking the loss of
privacy
and institution changes from the
previously review scheme and loss of
habitat and concerns about regarding
um Garden development and that is to
summarize the full objections details
a previous theme on-site was refused
earlier this year under delegate to
Paris as it was considered the design
appearance would be contrary to the area
and would impact on the amenity of 12
Elms race the rift and
the scheme has has been amended to
address these concerns and the
application now is a design and
appearance which is more characteristic
of the area
and also accept that changing Footprints
is not significant from The Refuge
scheme however those incremental changes
vulnerable schemes
are considered to change the planning
balance being mindful that we are in
this healthy Health balance and
therefore it's considered that any
adverse impacts of the scheme do not
simply or demonstrably outweigh the
benefits as such that the person is
considered Accord strategy pg-1 and the
air yet and is recommended for approval
subjects for conditions in your report
and the updates upon the condition in
the additional information
so this is just being existing
Enterprise street team and this is the
practice proposed and I feel all your
attention to the rare elevation
it's not first of all which you can see
is blank there are no windows and there
is a condition that would remove
committed development required to allow
Windows to be placed on that very
elevation to avoid overlooking to the
rear
and
just a personal site photographs just to
speak here I understand that the area
and then confirmation the previously
infused scheme
huh
thank you
thank you so much is Mr Beef in the
public area
yes Mr Lee
thank you
to get three minutes
can you hear me yes yes certainly can
thank you uh I am the occupier and owner
of the house of charnwood 12 elmsway
hail bars where we've lived since 1981.
I'll have to directly affected by the
planning application that I wish to
object to
my principal objection is that we will
be detrimentally overlooked by the
proposed development due to its
overbearing height and the distance from
the proposed house to miles
it is too close to the rear boundary and
certainly represents over development of
the garden site
the proposed development is too large
for the site with over a bear my house
and dominate our rear costs
according to the council's planning
guidelines for new residential
development the required distance
between the habit or room windows of
houses which face one another across
private Gardens should be 27 meters
the distance sharing on the drawing is
only
15.72 meters the distance from the
previous rejected application was 15.1
meters the increase in distance is there
by only 62 centimeters
attacks as hedge cannot be regarded as
permanent screening
the first planning application number
109768 was refused and the letter of
refusal written by Ms Rebecca Coley had
a planning and development on 14th of
March 2023 included the following the
purpose development by Regional is scale
massing and sighting in close proximity
the rear boundary would have an
overbearing and imposing relationship
onto 12 Ohm's way to the detriment of
the immunity that the occupies this
dwelling could reasonably expect to
enjoy and will be contrary to policy L7
of the traffic core strategy
The Proposal would not improve this
economic social and environmental
conditions of the area nor does it
comply with the development plan and
therefore does not comprise sustainable
development
the wording of this recusal is a very
strong condemnation of the previous
proposed development
apart from changes made to the design of
the house and an increase in the
distance between habitable rooms of only
61 centimeters which is still some 11
meters short for the council's planning
guidelines the footprint and height are
the same
the latest application does not meet any
of the planting planning Department's
criticisms made under the previous
reviews
it is astonishing that the planning
department feel that they can now
recommend the development after such an
overwhelming statement of refusal by the
head of planning
I would ask you to please refuse this
application as it is entirely
inappropriate on the site
thank you
thank you is Mr Gallup in the public
area I'm sorry Mr B if you step away
from the back door now thank you that's
your contribution coming back in the
next week it's the microphone thank you
I'm sure you get the drill by now yeah
yeah it's um I'm Simon agency yeah
yeah sorry
it's a relatable developers based in the
area so we're very only playing with the
location
several hundred yards away from this
side and we've done an awful lot to work
on building a house specifically
especially the conservation area and on
this application we have work with the
council very closely to ensure that the
Amendments required on a Thursday
without being carried out fully the knee
dwelling is in keeping with his
surroundings both architecturally
and it's a massive identity uh it's the
public is is 22.5 meters which is
actually wider than most of the bots on
the road and the garden space is
providing the reborn sufficient for the
existing University running
um the scheme balance is traditional and
contemporary architecture to mirror The
Wider Street Scene and it has a like a
hearing appearance the flexible
character area has the people inside an
officer
um the separating distances alluded to
by the name of the transcend league is
actually applied to first floor windows
we very carefully ensure there are no
windows at first of all level we've
simply use decorative brickwork and the
60 centimeters illegal so it's actually
spider Morris and we've pulled the
building back by about 1.2 meters and
what this means is now we exceed the 50
meter set out and the spg4 and the PG
the pg-1 and therefore the scheme is
fully compliant with Council policy
hence the recommendation for approval
um also I think it comments on the
hedging but you've got to understand
this kind of development privacy is
important for all parties so the first
thing we'll be doing we're doing and
we've include this part of the keys
advancing scheme is introduced a very
mature head to the back of the poverty
because currently there is overlooking
from 12 Ohm's range what is currently
playing the garden space so the idea is
we're going to screen us out and then I
previously become maintain going forward
um we needed an LFA that uh the
validation return this doesn't require a
flood resistance training strategy to be
submitted however we do agree with the
planning losses comments
in summary we believe that proposing is
complying with national a local policy
and we're therefore having the committee
agree with the officers recommendations
and approve it
thank you
guys very briefly explained comments and
separation
yes so so in terms of the
total room to habitable room and as we
noted that the first rule would not have
um actual rearing windows so they've
been removed and they're designed kind
of
um
so at the back there isn't it like first
of all there will be no overlooking
because from the first floor from ground
floor we don't consider them to be
overlooking because when you're a
groundwater park or there's no Vantage
points to appear to your neighbor and I
would remove like I said in the
introduction Community Development so
even if it was constructed somebody then
could put a better school window in that
relevation and without planning
permission when we'd be able to again
make that assessment they're designed
for scheme into three beds and they put
the windows on the side of the front so
we are satisfied that it meets the
universal policy thank you
to speak
that's all
thanks chair um I went to view this on
Sunday and
um
would you call drowned Harley Lane and
you can see that the properties there
are quite close together
and uh where the garage is where the
applications
it's a big space and it looks a bit a
bit odd if I'm honest with you the other
side of the road you know certainly not
terrorist houses in that area but uh you
know if they are quite close together so
and you look at the Block plan in the
plans
it isn't upkeeping with the area for
something you'll have the density of it
um
the configuration of the property
in relation to 12 Elms way that's the
issue that the resident is talking about
but I've looked at this and there have
been changes to the previous application
and I think it does fit fit in there
that hedge will be a mature hedge
building as the uh
yeah
speaker and family applications you've
said and I don't think it will not be a
friend
on number 12 that number 12 was worried
about
you know you have to be gapped in there
if you look at the time there's a huge
garden and uh
they're off set to this property to this
application property and as Miss known
said there's no windows in that top uh
second or first tomorrow so
um I'm happy with this application I
understand the resident to consider it I
really don't think it is outkeeping
similar properties in the area and the
other composer for drunkenness thank you
thank you sir
it's a difficult one isn't it because
there's no windows at the back
um on the first floor so that part is
obviously fine thing is it is still too
it is still two stories high on the back
and whilst you have them close
together and it's a bit odd having that
Gap Clearance Store as well and I I
completely agree with that part but I
think for me it's the the distance and
how they of it being it I guess it
hasn't witness reports but it's it is
still uh two-story High
and then that proximity to number 12 and
all the way along if you see from the
backs of the houses to the the houses of
the road behind they're all bigger so
for me it's it's
like almost at the back because it came
in a bit I probably need to be fine with
it I think it's but let's get that it
will sell a massing end of it for me
that is the issue rather than I get the
window part and I get that remove that
problem because otherwise
but I feel like it
kick in that sense it's not quite and
keep things with the rest of it so I was
hoping you're coming with a bit back and
then I'd be up okay yeah and I do think
it's a lot better than the previous
theme I mean
well this is a lot better but I think
it's not quite there so I can't really
support it thank you
yes
a second
which was really uh
my first instinct was
um
when I walked around the size of a lot
of plans particularly when I looked at
the the separation distance I've changed
my mind I think it's a difference not
from the original the original after
that protection to be
um
so we both proposed and seconded that we
accept this and I lost recommendation
all those in favor
thank you
the application the application site
relates to an L-shaped plot comprising
of a detached Valley to the north and an
area of gardenland to myself which
caused part of your wider site which has
been the subject of multiple proportions
for residential development so in order
to extend for someone which have lapsed
the application seeks permission for
such houses on the southern part of the
site printing Stanhope Road to the South
with the retention of the company's
agents existing driving limo Green Road
crunchy of over England to the West
the applications reported to supply and
development management committee
following receipts and less support from
six separate stresses
differs in several guards from the
previously committed scheme
isn't part an attempt to accommodate the
retention of the African savings
existing running back to the north of
the plot this has not been standing with
the condition 12. of the extent the
mission requires that the new trading
shall not be occupied until nine Beverly
Road has been demolished this having
been considered necessary because of the
unsatisfactory relationship between the
properties and in order to protect the
immunity of the future occupies of the
proposed dwellings and the occupies of
the existing planning
however the current proposal squeezes a
relationship between the proposed
development and that's the North degree
which is considered will be harmful to
residential immunity the retained well
exits close to the proposed weddings and
to the boundary itself called wrap
around the Northwestern core of the
development site the consequence of this
would be a smaller Garden area where the
Western dwelling that it retract changed
while they close the boundary leading to
an over barrier impact on the garden and
property of the western dwelling the
separation distance between the
employees across further Shores
council's guidance 15 meters reducing
from 30 meters to 11.5 meters
the West
in respect to the Eastern planning there
will be 12.1 meters between the balcony
the rear of the easternmost running the
second floor and the retained Brothers
Garden which falls short of the 13.5
when that's required that the
applicant's agent States the team tends
to occupy the return driving is not
relevant as planning Commissioners for
the land and not will be occupied and in
any events and personal commission would
need to be for the benefit of an
applicant rather than their ages
utility balance is engaged due to a lack
of near housing loan Supply although
taking this scheme at face value would
actually result in a net decrease of
three dwellings as it would produce the
delivery environment and the plots of
the West people have agreed to that was
the props to the north this further ways
against the sea example considered that
these identified adverse impacts that
could significantly logically outweigh
the benefits throughout the provision
when considered against the policies of
the MPP taking as a whole the
application is therefore recommended for
refusal just before I'm just before I
move on to me
I'm just going to show members
which shows what we're
trying to demonstrate so
that orange line and this this diagram
is being produced on a lower space by
our spatial dates team so it's verified
to the to the plots although it does put
two plants together so that's the
that's the existing planning Orange
the scheme here is the previous skin for
the two plots of the north which
wouldn't be able to come forward and
that's the position of the dwelling so
you can see that everything moves that
that bit closer when you get that live
site into the rear Garden which you
wouldn't have before so that that shows
the difference between the seams
so um the application that submitted
some uh further representations later on
this afternoon which we didn't have an
opportunity to write it before the
initial information report was published
so
um most of them repeat
comments which have already been
reported in either the main report to
additional information report so I won't
repeat those
um the the only the only two that I
could find that were not
um were not already reported in my way
or another was a suggestion that um we
couldn't use a 15 degree separation
Justice because inspector of Cellular in
a repair portable by the revenue the
most relevant uh however we have other
repair decisions which say it is so
there's nothing to members and also this
um as a contention Supply is woven
inadequate but again I've published on
the housing Supply position already
thank you
could you stand on which way around you
want to speak
the capsule
two couldn't have cancer today
and Mr Dave Japan
uh so yeah
um
regressively I'm currently unable to
attend in person as I'm away at the
business trip in Brazil
okay
the current application has been
submitted after thorough consideration
of green credentials under detailed
assessment
drama's intention is to continue
residing in existing drawing where
they've lived for 18 years with his wife
and 11 year old son should their
outpatient be approved
regarding the second reason especially
as well which is the most importance for
the members to know that Dr Ali is a
sole individual
affected by any of the perceived
concerns raised by officers
which pertains to overlooking and the
potential loss of privacy in the real
business space of the existing property
at nine boat regrowed on the right hand
side send the attached client
countries in the Committees reports the
issue of undo undue overlooking and
privacy on the right hand side so many
Touched volume does not relate to the
rear Garden of Doctor of his house
this Garden is set a little further back
and is not in direct view from the
Second Story main belly of window and
balcony on the realization that goes
right hand side
instead the area in question which is
overlooked at the distance of over 15
meters from the bedroom window to the
conservatory of the existing house
improves the paint area behind the
conservatory where the sex Recycling and
one gray bin are located
as well as The Chronic portion of the
driveway where two variety of positions
furthermore it's important to notice
that the tarmac portion of the driveway
and the two garages are already clearly
visible from public View and the
entrance case along low Green Road
it mentions and unacceptable over
varying impacts in relation to the rear
windows of extensively open from layout
of the left hand side
organized naked in the report to members
it is acceptable 56 of a new residential
development SVG does not specifically
address overbearing impacts in terms of
the 15 meter separation distance
to be clear the term overbearing is not
mentioned in a new residential
development
nonetheless there was a confliction in
paragraph 39 where the course States the
new residential
development SVG requires new residential
loans to result in acceptable and
abandoned price on mobile properties
it is important to know that Thermo
overgoing is not mentioned or referred
to in the mppf northern National design
guide in the context of overviews
respectfully this inconsistency this is
this is this inconsistency should be
carefully considered when evaluating the
first reason for refusal as the greatest
questions about precise requirements
outlined in the new essential
environment SBG and how they relate to
the concept about their presenting the
commission reports
this revision involves combining the
kitchen dining area recreational spaces
and a secondary home working area into
one expansive opening time area this
transformation creates a functional and
socially cohesive living space that not
only receives until natural Daylights
but also offers an improve their
development
Windows have been incorporated into the
side elevation offering clear views
extending nearly 25 meters across the
private community area
these windows play a crucial role
including the open finding ground floor
layouts with abundant Natural Life thus
significantly enhancing the overall
quality of living space and effectively
addressing concerns away since the
output
finally almost respectfully disagree
with the plumbing balance especially the
assertion of the tools Advance is not
engaged
in this case the number of drawings
already from this point from the
adjacent plots which is worth noting or
legally separated from the original form
and registered in independent names
through the external permission is not
relevant has changed those two over 60
Street each application is considered in
a certain modes with reference to the
site of specific circumstances
it's important to know that if any of
the extent planning missions were as
reconstructed they were inevitably
involved with the emotion of existing
problems therefore granting this
Planning Commission does not preclude
the addition of other doors in line with
the previous commissions that have been
grants
closed occupation aims to create a net
edition of two new market employable
residential homes
resulting in a mass addition of two
problems
this action directly addresses the
housing Shore teachers should be given
very significant weight in a
decision-making process
it also contributes to rectifying
truckers underserved five year as
announced by which I believe is
currently holding around the 3.5 year
line
in conclusion that two minor adverse
impacts of Grants and chronic missions
would not significantly the loss of our
way developers when assessed against the
policies in the throne room visible
especially considering a framework does
not reconcile service
with this in mind is that connected to
proceed
about that beach today
um Dr Alvin or councilmanship
one of them
thank you Council we've got five minutes
from when you press along
thank you for allowing me this
opportunity to speak on this application
some of you know that our third on this
committee for quite a few years so I do
have some background knowledge in this
decision making process
as such I genuinely feel that this
application is perfectly suitable for
this site
clearly from the report it is a close
call
the recommendation paragraphs at the end
of the report for each two reasons
but they are effectively the same single
reason separation distances within the
with the existing property line that
will be made
fleshing out by describing it twice does
not create two good reasons
added to this and the reason I mentioned
my planning experience
it is certainly not unheard of for
separation distances to be below those
featured in policies and guidelines in
the case of a close call on an otherwise
acceptable scheme and I believe that
this is an acceptable scheme decisions
are frequently made on balance over the
years I've heard more
more officers explain the acceptable
nature of reduced separation distances
but I have heard insistences on hearing
two policies and guidelines
so why not in this case
in that first paragraph of
recommendations the phrase undue sense
of enclosure is used in respect to the
boundaries of the properties
and uncomfortable to see such as
subjective assessment asserted and
surely it is inappropriate in a formal
report
so in fact just one reason is given to
explain the recommendation to refuse and
that leaves them the experience tells us
from other applications it's so often
interpreted with plasticity in its
application to decision-making
or furthest support for the case against
a decision based just on separation
distances a very useful visual to
illustrate this site is the shadowing
report that is contained on the
application details online and it
features the various combinations of
properties and the shadowing at
different times of day in so doing it
shows the wider context of the existing
potential dwellings sitting side by side
and it's well worth taking a look even
at this late stage because it adds so
much to to the picture to the points
they're making
there was as the report says just one
objection to this application that's
just one after two mail-outs to local
residents
uh this residential area does not sit
back uh if an issue presents itself if
this application held the prospective
harm to the neighborhood there would be
a plumber in the right position and we
do not have that indeed there are six
letters of support even though their
worth is then played down in the report
but there are six letters of support
just the one letter of objection
that's a given in my view the applicant
is close enough with the skin before us
for an approval to be granted
he is demonstrating his desire to add to
the number of dwellings Intrepid albeit
modesty number that's significant in its
own right
I don't just committed to see that
separation distances are not make or
break they are a decision to take on
balance and it is more than about us but
I urge you to approve this application
thank you chairman uh thank you
councilman Dr Robert
uh
thank you
thank you very much first of all I
disagree the fundamental aspect of the
Institute balance
I launched an appeal on plot three where
it says the Bandit there and I won that
I've actually won four appeals against
the capsule so I had the extensively
research to it being selfish and
mathematical and two have been on
applications where I would have only had
their 20 chance of actually winning
and no wonder Elon plot 3 which I have
in the front of me I'm sure planners are
familiar
the inspector which is actually extent
at the moment as I decided the inspector
actually said it'd be a net increase of
one dwelling
so if you can see behind me when the two
dwellings are in the existing house was
and there's one dwelling where it says
the Panic so I wanted to put two
drawings where the panic bars and we
watched the existing house
so even though demolished exists
permission was to demolish the existing
house and get two dwellings on the
Bandit it was a net increase of one
dwelling the inspector didn't say that
there was expanding already with
existing house and
he would encount those two I'm sorry I
totally disagree with that assertion
um and there's many other points but
unfortunately short time the gardens are
perfectly adequate is 23 meters squared
versus the recommended 80.
normally planning is based upon
affecting Neighbors
the only person affected by this in the
right hand corner is myself and that's
the conservatory at the back which is
actually useful and we're so convinced
yet or if the councilor says the
distance is overbearing where there's no
such term in any of the literature like
npf etc etc that would be any new
Resident would be aware of that
I refer that to an appeal actually the
council would launch against judicial
review of the neighborhood several years
ago and in that the cancer zone of
Barrister Road these distances were 10.5
and 11.5 meters
and
the argument lost the judicial view
these distances are far greater
the Kansas Barrister's rate leads
guidelines are not prescriptive
University potential development they're
not Council acknowledges that are
rigidity here the space expanded and
stifle creativity and Design
the honorable Judge of this is a high
court judge on the Immunity on that
particular decision
uh wrote obviously unarguable
he said the second floor balconies on
one house I marginally include glucose
by references rather than boundary
and can be treated by appropriate family
treatment emergency
and actually if you look at the distance
the recommended at 15 the fractions of
those researching bins
the windows are three meters tall
so there'll be a 1.8 liter fence so
you'll actually only see 1.2 meters at
the house and at only two week windows
on the side
yeah she says will be inhibited because
in some windows but there's four windows
and even if you build on that side he
said there'd only be a one meter but
if you build on that side you have to
demolish the original house anyway so
there goes all the alternates so I'm
sorry you understand these arguments
okay thank you very much
[Music]
I think
I think the points that most is is that
is trying to have this always so what's
the benefits of some of the schemes this
benefits available and to sort of Jigsaw
them all together to get
um the outcome that he said that he's
okay but he can't but you can't either
those permissions are extent or not
either we take them into account or not
either there's more dwelling support
there's not more dwellings you can't say
there's more dwellings than
demolish one and not replaceable two so
um as far as we're concerned this is in
the way that this has been
shown to be or acceptable by the
applicant that means the loss because
that that's the only way so the benefits
of having the overtime to the West
and the town Drive is the north the East
London Street dwellings so no tilted
balance because we wanted to live
streamed
then you have an adverse impact if you
say okay the two run into the West exist
well that's fine but then you can't save
as an Outlook to the west but
um that would mitigate the impact to the
north
um I suppose on the owner Baron Point
um it's not in the uh
policy framework nor is it in the SPG
but it is
um most fundamentally in those statutory
starting point for decision making
developer which is an L7 very very
distinctly in there and there's only
reason to resist planning applications
the uh the separation just sits in the
short they're too short as far as we're
concerned now they were slightly short
before
but now they are have there there has to
be a typical somewhere otherwise you
know you've been right up against the
blunderman and that wouldn't be
acceptable we think that that Line's
been across there's no sense of balance
there's no extra houses to put into the
into the balance and therefore the
recommendation is is for refusal
thank you
you can see where it's going cutting the
entire thing with Peter approach this
way I can see it
um but I think that the officers are a
fantastic job of explaining actually
not just saying if people don't really
actually explaining all the details and
I can't see anything that I disagree
with you know both at all so I can't say
that I'm more than happy to propose if
he refuses
um
report
because it's just I also think it's not
the right thing to help us
um but yes
recommendation thank you bye thank you
Council manager
thanks Jeff I mean this is a a very
difficult one to navigate as it's a
complicated piece with many previous
funding applications
planning was explained
um and it does in a way feel wrong that
we're losing the hats you know believing
the main house that was built but I
think the planning teams do put
conditions in
important and the conditions not being
there in the house hasn't been
demolished so the the application comes
but also we have to recognize that
explains why the head planning I think
the separation distance and how
important they are in planning terms and
they're there for a reason and I think
if we would go against
we've put ourselves in a tricky position
and future applications
so I kind of feel that if there was a
way that the main house could be kept it
would mean that the current plan of
notification would need to be amended
and I think that's what the um needs to
go away because
um
issues
Road
the
application to clear the site and erect
six units and three pairs of
semi-detached loans the dwellings will
face towards delamere road to the east
parking spaces will be provided
adjacency
the application proportions of 50
because six or more or lessons of
infections will receive contributes the
office of recommendation
for consideration of the principal of
residential development together with
the proposal to design residential
Liberty from the highway of parks
results in the creation of six
additional dwellings in the contrary to
the council's housing land Supply as
long as a small amount of economic
benefit resulting in the construction
process
proposed development is consistently
acceptable in terms of the principle of
Housing Development on the site it's
designed and appearance the impact on
the residential immunity properties held
regards Highway matters there are some
limited concerns regarding the potential
for overlooking of the Greer Gardens to
the proposed properties from an existing
first of all happened to the room window
and barclaying the side of the date of
the adjacent property the office is
considered the limited adverse impacts
in this respect but not significantly
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
granting commission when assessed
against the policies of the mdps and the
proposal and the proposal composed with
the development plan would take as a
whole as such the application is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions
hello
and that's what I've got to find out
you've got three minutes from one year
first of all thank you
thank you chair for allowing me to
address the committee this evening my
name is Conrad Keller managing director
of Landmark property group we're an
award-winning residential developer of
high quality housing schemes across
South Manchester
and we welcome the officer's
recommendation to improve the planning
application confirming the scheme is
policy compliance and represents a
sustainable development on the key
ground field site
following the closure of the education
center in 2021.
we can work proactively with the
officers over a number of months to
ensure that the scheme presents it to
you today not only brings back a disused
site in a prime residential location but
also provides for a development which
appropriately responds to its
surroundings particularly given insights
constraints
in particular in taking careful
consideration of the consultation
responses received and comments made by
your planning officers the scheme has
been redesigned from that which was
originally submitted to reduce the
number of dwellings proposed from eight
to six
to better reflect the surrounding
residential density and specific design
context of adjacent properties
the proposal has been designed to an
exceptionally high quality incorporating
the detailed guidance contained within
the council's graphic design code
Azure officer Notes The Proposal made
sufficient use of land and is in keeping
with the character and urban green of
the surrounding area
importantly the highways evidence which
is being accepted by the council's
highways officer not only demonstrates
the scheme can be appropriately
accommodated on the site without
adversely impacting on the surrounding
highways Network
but there is sufficient on and off
street parking opportunities to meet
demands
indeed extensive parking surveys
demonstrate there is sufficient capacity
to accommodate the proposal along
delamere and flixton Roads The Proposal
also includes opportunities for safe and
secure bicycle storage in accordance
with planning policy requirements
the other technical evidence submitting
in support of the proposed proposal
demonstrates that the proposal is policy
compliance
and there are no grounds upon which to
support the refusal of the development
in particular further work to assess the
implications of noise of surrounding
uses has been undertaken demonstrating
there will be minimal impacts on
residents immunity
to conclude the scheme representative
positive Investments on a key Brownfield
site which has been designed to ensure
it is sympathetic to its surroundings
whereas creating a high policy scheme
which significantly improves the
Aesthetics of the surrounding area and
provides much needed family housing in
Trafford thank you for your time
thank you
anywhere to speak
councilman
I suppose this is
totally the opposite the one we just
dealt with confusing that this one is
pretty straightforward in my view and I
propose to uh
approve this for the obvious reason
mentioning the reports and especially
you know the provision of six
family homes for the community so I have
to post it but we approve it thank you
thank you
[Music]
well with very difficulty I wish to
support this
um
application I remember many many years
ago it was the youth center which I
attended
absolutely sorry
but
um life is life isn't it it changes and
um I I think that basically if we don't
get this scheme of the houses and I
think it is
something worse
laughs
should be subjected yeah yeah
thank you Patrick
scheme which is a good scheme
there's more houses
thank you
[Music]
yeah I'm also gonna support this game I
can't stand the rest of the series
because it is quite a tight spot
different
it's a good start for the housing and I
think um I think really in in the report
over 41 about separation systems I think
they are good enough
um 70 meter gap between the hospital
room windows and but also every
paragraph history
as well so I think that if another
assurance that of residents
foreign
construction stage
um whether there'd be any effect there
um
it's such a beautiful condition 10
there's a whole construction
Environmental Management plan but it's
required to be submitted and we'll show
you that
there are many requirements within it to
ensure that the construction
works with the minimal disruption there
will be some I mean there always is
um
sorry just with it being a civil Street
as well
because that can be closed every morning
in the afternoon yeah
okay
they will have to deal with that okay
um
particularly the
caliber he spoke very beautifully when
he explained in each and everything
about this housing
academic education I mean he covers all
the area in a very short time how many
people died so hopefully support this
application
so it's been proposed and seconded that
we've brought this around us
recommendations
um
111258 there's McDonald's restaurants in
Davie Park hours
thank you sir
um
the application voice the McDonald's
restaurant situated in tropical retail
Park to the west of Boston Road
the applicant seeks permission to amend
condition for attached to a previous
classifying commission 105 637 full 21.
to allow for an extended 24-hour
operation for restaurants drive through
the main restaurants continue to operate
in accordance with the approved hours
0500 to midnight
playing commission 105
637-421 currently restricts the
operation of the drive fees the hours
above 500
200. so it has to close
for three hours during the night
the application is reported to committee
that has been called in by Catholic
accordingly
your key issues for consideration of
potential impacts on residential amenity
and highly stroke parking
um
so I'm just running through
I'll just go watch that we're going to
listen just run through if it's the way
you can see the site
um
with the Residential Properties on the
on the opposite side of Wellington Road
to these other residential units on the
retail clock to the West
North and South
um
looking South along Barton Road
[Music]
um
North on the bottom of the West Central
properties and that's the Southern Road
the photograph of the boundary with the
Residential Properties
so
primary commission has recently been
granted the adjacent Starbucks site
which is on the the site for the South
um on the opposite side of a merry way
um
right
20 has recently gone to the Starbucks to
operate its price through the associate
on a 24-hour basis
that was grants on the 20th of June 2022
the application was supported by the
noise impact assessment
included that 24-hour operation at the
Starbucks drive-through would not Resort
and then like in an unacceptable noise
immunity impacts on the chosen
Residential Properties
in regards to this and the fact that no
complaints have been received by
environment protection
in relation to the drive through
operations are either Starbucks ornament
times
the council's Environmental Protection
news Institute has raised no objections
in relation to potential employers more
likely impacts on nearby restaurants
operations of the McDonald's
drive-through
in terms of residential amenity or
antisocial Behavior
the previous application also included a
noise impact assessment
premises noise management plan which are
also consider to be relevant in the
Kurds application
taking these factors into account
it is considered that the project Center
hours of use of the drive to government
would not have an unacceptable impact on
residential community
subject to appropriate conditions
including conditions that be used as
operated in accordance with the site
management plan premises noise
management plan
and noise impact assessment
a local Power Authority is also raising
objections to extended hours of
operating
and the further that will also consider
structure in terms of hiring price
thank you
thank you today uh Miss Jones
across the microphone I would yes but um
you pretty much just said everything I
was going to say to be honest so
um
I'm not sure what else I can answer that
because I have pretty much covered
everything in my own speech
um from what you've what you've just
said as well
um as you said my name is Zoe Jones I'm
the area manager for McDonald's
turned off actually
that's it okay yeah
um I my name is Zoe Jones I'm the area
manager for McDonald's working with a
franchisee at restaurants
um I've been in McDonald's for over 30
years so I've known him very well in the
natural live not very far just around
the corner from this particular site so
I do know the enemy very well
um
as you know as you you just said then
um we've had planning permission
recently granted to go from 5am to 2 A.M
in the morning and we're obviously
closing the restaurant to the public a
child and 12 midnight
um and obviously the Starbucks which I'm
not sure that gives you just the right
picture actually of where how close it
is where it is literally just across the
road and they operate
um 24 hours drive through only
um in the Starbucks
we haven't
experienced any
um
anti-surgical Behavior or any noise
pollution or anything since they have or
even since we have gone
um you know to the plant pot
um closing and so you know as you said
in terms of objections I don't actually
think that it will be
um you know in terms of we sorry so
again in terms of McDonald's we have
very stringent policies and procedures
in place in terms of litter and dealing
with neighbors and we like to say you
know I just think that we are very good
with our neighbors
um we also all our managers very well
trained in terms of managing conflicts
and anything like that we have good
policies and procedures in place we're
out to deal with that so if in the
unlike the event if anyone's concerned
about antisocial Behavior we are very
well equipped to deal with that Indian
Land the event that it does happen
um and as you can see there it is
um right on the cost of the M60 it runs
right alongside the M60 so
I don't know if you know the area very
well what I I agree that the majority of
the traffic that we will get into the
restaurant will be people that are
already passed in that area there's also
the 24-hour restaurants sort of in the
Eccles area so most people that would be
visiting that area would be going there
because they never live there or they're
going to visit I can't see people from
Eccles heading over to this particular
restaurant for instance
um just because we've gone 24 hours
okay so thank you very much anyway thank
you you're stormy Thunder thank you
yeah I mean I I know this very well
and
I do have some concerns
24 hours I think
um disconnected probably certainly
the president of Starbucks
and I think this is extending now and
you can first see that if they're not on
the track now
the objection but I think
um if
there are houses that are quite close
but they're on the other side
and I think they have enough
currently
you know up to 12 o'clock
across across that particular area
and I think
um
it's probably remiss if we might be of
this committee access to the treasuries
people
but that's just
okay thank you Council uh Council
thank you chair
when this retail Park was first opened
residence on The Wendy Stakes were all
told nothing would ever open beyond 10
pm
and
and that's not true anymore
there are
five different food Outlets
on that area
and the thought of
any of them opening 24 hours fills me
with dreads I regularly get complaints
from residents about the litter
from the takeaways what tends to happen
is people drive around the roundabout
onto Shetland way which is the road on
the rise and then Park up
sometimes going down the side on the
left sometimes just parking on Shetland
way they eat their food and they dump
their rubbish
in people's Gardens and in the parking
area and it's a mess around there
the rubbish that's blown and it ends up
where all the shrubs are they collapse
there
the Midland Gardens are elderly people
the people on the opposite side it's a
mixture of
the first two blocks you see are flats
and
going vertically the ones horizontally
are small family houses
and people that complain about the
rubbish that's left now
that isn't the fault of
the fast food places they accept that
however it's a consequence
and the thought of yet another
Place being open 24 hours I did not
support Starbucks being open 24 hours
and I absolutely do not support this
thing over in 24 hours right next to the
motorway Junction
there's already a McDonald's open 24
hours
a couple of Stones Throw It Away don't
need another one so close to a
residential area and so I'm proposed
but we reject this planning application
thank you
thank you Council Council Ashford
um yeah I just thought I said I I don't
really see that adding a few more hours
of opening time is really going to make
a massive difference of the big problems
that these residents have I know they do
have problems with littering nothing
else to set the issue in a way
um so I would approve the application
but I really think that the residents
deserve a better deal and that Madonna
should have somehow with their tune that
takes place there
was your objection rather than the
opening hours
[Music]
yeah it's too close it's a nice
ways yeah
thank you
um
one of the
counselor accordingly mentioned that
by making suspense for our operation
would be creating a service station by
itself I think that's a reasonable
comment to make really
um I'm not 100 either way but
um
I feel like I'm on the refuse side to be
honest
the residents on the opposite side are
detected by quite large trees
um which I think
doesn't really create a good item on the
on the lights pollution side I think
they'll do well protected from the light
pollution
um but the fact that Starbucks have 24
hours granted already I don't think
we've been really
um put too much weight on that and we've
got to really look at this as a single
application on its own Merit
um
with the noise I think if I was written
there granted I'm not
I think the noise produced by cars going
past the Morris will be more of it
concerns me than speaking through a
speaker
at McDonald's however I also feel that
the area doesn't need any more reason to
create issues of their health
I do have concerns from comments made by
residents around that I think that's a
real consideration that we want to think
about
I've seen the state of areas around
McDonald's and even though McDonald's
have robust bottles in place to to
ensure that the area is clean that's
only there are some of the one that they
they run themselves so I am concerned
that there are legitimate concerns where
he's around that and it would really
really
um
so I am going to go towards the reviews
um I think I suppose
colleagues in terms of what they've said
about but the application
I thought I'd find myself seeking
infinite favor up when it came in but I
do think
um I think just said I've got a bear in
mind that the president's already been
set but also in terms of what's actually
from Thomas in terms of it's the
exception of last time for a couple of
hours so in terms of the evidence in
front of us in terms of the impact and
the noise I think I mean any more in
terms of the difference in my currently
closes to work proposed and that's he
really did have to do it for us
headache uh
just just one
just one
um that are
um controlled by
their own regulation I think was a
circular which effectively says what a
Motorway service station is and what it
isn't so
you can't give any weight to the idea
that this might become a Motorway
service station because that is not
what's in front of you
foreign
um so okay so they are saying that's
great I'm just wondering whether is
there um
about it
there is a planning around on health
grounds isn't it having
effectively
fast food as in
um it being detrimental to people
help I wonder whether that's the reason
why one could have it but otherwise
I guess I mean we don't want we don't
have breastmans necessarily and each
application is its own you have at
Starbucks doesn't already have it so
um
not really
counselor
and like everybody else I'm really
struggling with it
um but it is only a few hours uh extra
um the litter is the vein of my life and
it's and it's fast food rubbish as well
as the uh
paraphernalia that we find
um
and there is another one and I said
that's over 24 hours I believe which is
supposed to be down the road and it's
not drive through but it's a restaurant
um I'm struggling
yeah I I struggled a little bit with
this
extension through 10 o'clock to midnight
this extensions already
um
allowed starving to do this and to be no
complaints of being so well except
they're not quite the same they're not
quite the same kind of business model
they're so similar as to us so I'm happy
to close that we accept this allow the
box of recommendation there because of
second that
okay thank you Council Dickey so
it's just a good comment
um you mentioned
in the first place is not it's not on
that it's not on their site you can't
expect them to clear up stuff that isn't
their responsibility so what do they do
do they just end up in Gold bags
um that they I suppose that
what we could
events
foreign
um granted we we need to do better with
it but we do do that
and we do it past Starbucks
um
yeah number two about parking why the
people
belonging in the second planet because I
do every single day
this is ample parking there I mean but I
don't think it's any sensible drivable
parking on Check Line Road and we have
an um hundreds of portable spaces and
number two I disagree this is sorry
constantly saying oh health issue it is
a McDonald's and it is already open till
12 o'clock so and we have a president
cost crossword
although there's a difference I mean
coffee shop is often off with the night
time I understand McDonald's
so it will make a difference a little
bit more generally
the local residents will not come over
there it is because it's a motor of
attention and the people are traveling
throughout the night and they can stop
over and have a food and go and this is
on the very ideal device and of course
most application
but it's much straight talk please
together
propose a second if that we accept this
in uh
okay so that that's been passed along
with absolute recommendations and we've
gone 20 minutes past when we normally
take a break we've got two items left on
the agenda and I suggest that we do take
a quick five minute break for them then
we do the last two yeah
thank you
very much
foreign
thank you
there's an apology
um
we'll have this the statements spread
out by Miss Curly from Council price
then we go into Club sessions which of
the camera discusses you need to
describe to them
introduction
thank you chair the application notes
for two-story semi-touch prophecy on
the north side of the Riddim Road into
play
seeking funded permission for the
direction of two suicide a single part
two-story Road Extension and single
story printings French extension
including a front porch the application
was reported to Planet Equity because
it's encoded by Council of France one
injection has been received from the
adjacent property number 49 the main
concerns with scale of the proposal and
the impact on loss of light to the
dwelling they're looking at the rear
Garden in patronum president October
49ers policy we're also concerned
regarding notes noise and dust and from
the building Works parking impacts and
damage to poverty in addition to impact
on people with protected characteristics
although amended plans have been
received reduce the scales proposal the
objection remains is acknowledged the
given the orientation of the site the
pro-site extension would cause a degree
of overshadowing to number 49's bay
window and side door however following
an adoption of the first floor rear
extension is considered that impact
would be limited in addition the
haptical room served by the bay window
inside door has another source supplies
on the rear elevation
therefore I'm about
to logout sorry
considered an acceptable impact of God's
source of life no first floor windows
are proposed on the side elevation that
would no habitually inside because on
the side elevation and directly patient
13 at 49. there is a bathroom window but
this will be conditioned as a stick
shouldn't have to slow place
it's recognized that the development
would cause a degree of noise Industrial
in the construction phase however this
is coming to all new developments and
given the scale of the development any
description would be limited and
temporary any damage Clause to the
adjacent property through the
development is a civil matter between
the two parties
representations have been considered
considered an action taken to minimize
the impact of the conditions and
informative it's therefore considered
while the person wouldn't have a degree
of impact this would be an exceptional
impact on all residents including those
with perceptive characteristics The
Proposal is considered to be of design
scale that is appropriate within the
contact as such as recommended for
approval subjects to the conditions
within the report thank you and the
informative group in there
things
thank you this is a statement from
Council Bluffs this application may
appear to be very similar to other
wraparound development plans as a
submitted on a weekly basis however
there are concerns about just how close
it comes to the neighboring properties
the original concerns have not
materially changes the results of
reduction in the depth of the proposed
development into the back Garden
that is building line still comes very
close to the boundary between numbers 47
and 49. this means there are material
considerations around one the scalar
massive proposed development the gap
between the building and the bandage
fairly wise on the wheel again according
to the plans and two bottom light The
Residence at 49 have explained that
there will be a significant loss of
life's location as those living space
and garden as a result of how close the
development is coming to the boundary we
understand the usefulness of the
development just limited if the width of
the extent will be reduced on the side
however if it was only Built as one
story instead of two that was
significantly reduce the impact of this
development of 49 even if the plug width
or distance out towards the bound July
or maintain
curly could we stop broadcasting that
could we load the two doors as well
first